6 33 this past week new numbers were
released by a clark county school
district about drug use on campus and
it's shocking this report shows ccsd
police responded to nearly 1400 calls
regarding illegal drugs the alcoholman
sharing reaction from a valley counselor
this morning bianca
good morning john good morning heather
well valley educators they were upset to
hear about the five students that took
pills that were possibly laced with
fentanyl and matter of fact one of those
students 15 years old died after taking
those pills so this latest report was
shared by ccsd pd and this is about drug
use across the valley and so according
to that report marijuana is the most
popular drug among students alcohol is
second and tobacco nicotine third there
is a category that says other it's
unclear on what those drugs are and then
not coded means the drug type was not
identified
i've also been seeing a lot of pill use
recently
i actually have been talking a lot about
this recently because of
fentanyl and i
personally lost a friend to that
so that was faith harper she's a youth
counselor she sees a lot of students
addicted to prescription medications
possibly similar to what the kids at
sedway middle school were taking and
also other drugs that were listed on
that list include hallucinogens also
crack cocaine and methamphetamines those
were of course on the lower amounts and
again taking this morning just to talk
to your student and child about drug use
and the dangers about it and protecting
our kids again valley educators want
something to be done about this bianca
holman live local now